[Musique]
c'est bientôt l'été et en maillot de
bain rouge cet été du coup je change mon
alimentation il me faut une poêle des
légumes verts
de l'huile d'olive
il y a plus qu'à attendre que ça la
crise
mais cris dans un mois on se barre d'ici
j'en ai marre de deux touches de son
plafond d'avoir cette mezzanine
où je déjà moi j'ai ma blessure c'est
mon pied le fou là-dedans il reste trois
saisons pleines mais ses meubles il ya
un fou qui est important quand même il
ya un four sur le placard oui migron ben
merde quoi bayer et j'ai fait du fromage
devants
rapidement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
mais donne tes pièces majeures
au [ __ ] on les bat montech dans un
cagibi
tâche
qui m'est fait le con j'avais l'idée
mais je vais construire 20 kg vignes
pour des gens mais vendredi on en parle
de ça
mekkaoui c'est ce qu'a promis là dedans
obligé de foot mes lunettes comment n'y
a pas de table de nuit dans une barre de
la météo
[Musique]
comme
nous
[Musique]
m
l'eau potiche
l'opti le petit chat qui court dans la
maison une petite
[Musique]
non
là
[Musique]
parce que
nous avons vaincu